première partie de ce journal donc dédié
aux élections municipales deux invités à
suivre dans cette édition est d'abord
jean michel fourgous bonsoir bonsoir mr
les républicains d'elancourt président
de saint quentin en yvelines vous serez
candidat donc pour un nouveau mandat
dans la ville où vous êtes élu depuis
1996 vous mènerez la liste alliés
l'encours cette décision de vous
représenter ce qu'elle était évident
pour vous ça nécessitait tout de même un
peu de réflexion de votre part nous
c'est une liste d'union très élargie
très rassemblée sur la base des
compétences et genre plus de 50% de la
liste ne revient du secteur associatif
et après vous avez l'ensemble des
grandes du grand courant elle est rude
et quelques j'en ai l'air est mené à
quatre
et puis un peu de centre-gauche ont
baissé c'est vraiment une liste de
compétences et je rappelle souvent que
les idéologies diviser les compétences
rassemblées aujourd'hui une équipe
municipale plus que jamais je trouve
joie dans les sondages on chante 15 %
quasiment des français sentent que les
clivages gauche droite sont dépassés
masse et bien que tous les maires toutes
les listes montre bien qu'elle
accompagne ce phénomène même pas de
clivage même si vous êtes toujours
adhérent à aux républicains il y aura
lui leur sensibilité politique dans sa
raquette ou simple que presque donc
c'est tendance mais chacun mais sa carte
avec un renouvellement à y aller tout le
monde est alors un renouvellement nous
est 50% plus les six ans vous avez
quasiment sur l'ensemble des listes de
prayssas rentreront en euros
nouvellement donc un grand projet est
bien sûr
et l'on courait à la chance d'avoir un
d'abord en termes d'emploi si on regarde
les attentes de nos administrés l'emploi
bien sûr impossible
c'est une niveau économique que vous
avez bon vous êtes un bassin d'emploi
quand même très très riche il encourt
saint quentin paris saclay ces six et
demi de chômage c'est des emplois plutôt
de très haute valeur ajoutée c'est c1 je
crois un emploi pour servir des emplois
pour un actif dont on est quand même
assez un modèle économique des très
belles boîtes sur des secteurs d'avenir
que l'on accompagne d'ailleurs avec bien
sûr saint quentin en yvelines mesure
ensuite vous avez le deuxième c'est
l'éducation éducation et l'emploi est
devenu un modèle scolaire en france la
preuve
l'école de formation de l'éducation
nationale vient de se mettre avec en
cours et comme je disais à former 4000
profs parents dans cette avec la
nouvelle pédagogie donc française
aujourd'hui qu'on entrait dans la
pédagogie du numérique voilà est
également les douze communes se sont mis
sur ce même modèle et l'éducation
nationale d'ailleurs vient le 5 février
je crois faire son plus gros colloque
national au vélodrome dont vous êtes
tous les âges et tous les inspecteurs
d'une question simple clic trail sur
cette nouvelle pédagogie non voyants ont
livré mon coeur de la réforme de
l'éducation nationale de la
modernisation là donc ça c'est pour
l'éducation avec un objectif élevé à nos
objectifs sur nous on se fonde que sur
dix ans si on prend un enfant au
primaire au secondaire et qu'il arrive
au supérieur avec en plus l'université
paris 5 et qui va devenir la première
université française lui et ce qui va
intégrer pleinement cette université à
l'horizon 2025 absolument venir c'est de
saint quentin qui va intégrer
paris serait donc en fait on on
travaille sur un parcours de réussite
scolaire du primaire jusqu'à cette
université qui sera bien ce nuage très
scientifique très
dkny très numérique d'ailleurs et bien
entendu les enfants qui ont la chance de
rentrer dans ce processus aura un
avantage on vise même l'augmentation de
la performance scolaire environs de près
de 30%
donc s'il bien sûr suivent tout le
cursus avec cette nouvelle pédagogie
on a même une classe d' autisme parce
qu'en fait tous ses moyens aujourd'hui
permet d'intégrer donc on est une des
rares communes de france
à voir
une classe six spéciales pour l'autisme
oui c'est ça permet une ouverture
fantastique donc je vous dis économie
enfin emploi éducation a pressé la
sécurité sécurité c'est une
problématique qui intéresse davantage
les habitants
aujourd'hui les nos habitants nous il
encore toi sont très sensibles aux
problèmes de sécurité ils me font part
régulièrement et donc nous on a monté de
trois policiers a reçu municipaux à 32
aujourd'hui quand même en puissant armée
aujourd'hui à une brigade canine une
brigade équestre vous avez un centre de
vidéo quand même de plus de 100 caméras
et surtout vous avez ce fameux
commissariat du futur donc
d'agglomération qui arrive à elancourt
grâce au giro dont il faut quand même le
dire et bien entendu qui va avoir les
meilleures technologies les meilleurs
moyens bien sûr pour assurer les
meilleures conditions de sécurité
d'une part pour bien s'occuper des
victimes pour bien protéger si nos
policiers et puis pour que la justice et
la police donc soit encore plus rapides
plus fiables voilà donc des conditions
de sécurité qui vont augmenter mais
attention il faut quand même trois ans
pour le construire
ensuite vous avez un projet sportif de
haut niveau avec les fameux jeux
olympiques une fois dans la carrière
dans une vue ville vous voyez les jeux
olympiques donc les enfants auront la
chance de ils vont voir ça sert d'être
inhérentes aux actionnaires ça va
permettre de développer un esprit
sportif bien auprès des jeunes en termes
d'intégration les valeurs de
l'entreprise entrepreneurs elles sont
assez proches des valeurs de ce sport
c'est les forces et c'est une sorte
d'autonomie une force psychologique vous
trouvez en soi même japon et donc on va
beaucoup travailler là-dessus lordon la
colline de la course avec l'adhésion ses
40 ans que tout le monde se dispute sur
un projet avait coûté ça va être à peu
près à l'occasion de mettre tout le
monde d'accord avec lille de loisirs il
ya un projet commun entre eux sur sept
cette fameuse colline des locaux et il y
le loisir et ça va permettre de faire
des pistes cyclables ce qui est un plan
vélo comme ya trois sites vélo sur les
quatre le youth le golfe les trois sites
vélos vont être rassemblés autour de
l'île des loisirs ils vont permettre
vraiment une transformation cette île de
loisirs avec dans le cadre des jeux
olympiques d'avoir des moyens qu'on
n'aurait jamais eu de plusieurs
priorités pour ce nouveau mandat sur
lequel voilà vous êtes candidat merci
jean michel fourgous d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire sortant d'elancourt président
également saint quentin en yvelines et
vous êtes la tête de liste allez
elancourt aux élections municipales en
face de vous pour le moment une seule
liste déclaré une liste de gauche
réinventons elancourt qui est menée par
catherine perron peindre faste